el fiscal de Texas sometido a juicio
político el congreso Texano votará la
destitución del fiscal general del
estado que en paxton en una rueda de
prensa previa su comparecencia ante el
congreso paxton invitó a sus seguidores
a manifestarse en contra de lo que él
califica como un regalo a la
administración del presidente Joe biden
el hecho de que se me prohibiera
presentar pruebas para defenderme revela
que este vergonzoso proceso se fraguó
desde el principio como una retribución
política está previsto que esta votación
tenga lugar el sábado a la 1 de la tarde
y quiero invitar a mis conciudadanos y
amigos a que acudan pacíficamente y
hagan oír su voz mañana en el Capitolio
ejerzan su derecho de petición ante su
gobierno
paxton enfrenta 20 acusaciones por parte
del Congreso entre las que están los
cargos de corrupción abusa de confianza
e incapacidad para el cargo si El
veredicto del hemiciclo Texano es
positivo el fiscal destituido
automáticamente
es un poco diferente el proceso Federal
en el que un funcionario acusado puede
permanecer en el cargo hasta un juicio
en el senado pero un movimiento de la
cámara hoy mañana o en cualquier momento
durante el fin de semana podría remover
a paxton de su cargo para el futuro
previsible
gameton republicano es un nardo crítico
del gobierno de Joe biden en 2020 pidió
formalmente a la Corte Suprema que
anulará la victoria del demócrata